Nick Carter defense Justin Bieber Bieber  may have a bad rep for his bad-boy past  but nick tells al magazine the Biebs  couldn't hold a candle to what he and  the Backstreet Boys did in their heyday  that's why he and aj mclean say they are  glad social media wasn't a thing back  then so what kind of trouble did bsp get  into aj tells the mag just anything from  me being drunk or irate at a club or me  walking naked down the hallway in a  hotel for no apparent reason just random  stuff that never really got out thank  God as for boy bands these days Howie  Dorough says he thinks the key to their  longevity has been in their showmanship  and as the group told us just last month  therapy Thank You counsel  [Music]